i was honored that you asked me to write
the forward but when you first asked me
to write the forward the first thing i
said was girl
yeah you don't need a forward everybody
knows who you are
and i wrote what i believe in my heart i
actually said that
your words healed our wounds and
resurrected our spirits
i think it was a shot of light you know
it was just like
whoa an infusion of light came into
people's lives
what's magnificent about this poem
when you analyze it there isn't a word
that is wasted you know i'm a poetry
reader and have been for years
but my favorite uh passage or piece of
the poem
is when you say we braved the belly of
the beast
we've learned that quiet isn't always
peace
and the norms and notions of what just
is isn't always justice
and yet the dawn is ours before we knew
it
somehow we do it somehow we've weathered
and witnessed a nation that isn't
broken but simply unfinished
i think that saying our country isn't
broken it's just unfinished is really
hopeful
and hope is something we really need
more of right now
and you obviously wanted people to feel
that when you wrote this
what did you want that takeaway
ultimately from the poem to be
i wanted that to be the takeaway which
is why i'm so glad that you just read it
which for me i think looking at our
democracy is something that's unfinished
is both hopeful but it's also reflective
it's also interrogative meaning that it
both says
we have work to do and we can accomplish
it
in the poem i wanted to speak of hope
and unity
but it had to be rooted in a sense of
purpose
and dignity because i think unity for
the purpose of
unity without interrogation can just be
toxic
mob mentality it's not thinking about
what are the reasons that we're linking
arms and so i wanted to really
underscore this idea that the american
project
is a process and it's not something that
i think we've arrived at yet as a
country but something that we can
continue
to labor for out of love well as a 23
year old
to have such um
discernment and great
perspective on everything that's
happened
and particularly everything that's
happened in recent years
with the country's divisiveness how
strongly divided we all
have become how canceled culture
has affected almost everyone how
the world literally shifted in front of
us during the pandemic
but you were able to do it in in in one
poem and yes when you say and yes
we are far from polished far from
pristine but this doesn't mean we're
striving to form a union that is
perfect which i think people need to be
reminded of
because we keep hearing a more perfect
union we've heard that for years
but this doesn't mean we're striving to
form a union that is perfect we are
striving to forge
our union with purpose